buonasera a tutti pensavate di evitarvi
lo chef della giornata purtroppo anche
qui al ted c'è lo chef si accenderà di
luci allo chef si va in bagno c'è la
dieta depurativa
mi chiedo anticipatamente perdono però
oggi voglio raccontarvi in realtà una
favola non vi darò ricette strane
gustose eccetera eccetera
vi racconto una storia una favola perché
è una favola le favole spesso nascono
con l'obiettivo di trattare argomenti
difficili in modo soft
addirittura si parla dei lupi che
mangiano le nonne di bambini orfani nel
bosco eccetera eccetera
parlando con degli adolescenti quindi
vorrei trattare un argomento abbastanza
ostico sfruttando una storia una fiaba
il primo protagonista della nostra fiaba
si poteva intuire dal titolo dove ci
sono briciole ai sentieri ovviamente
pollicina non può mancare pollicino un
bambino che vive in una famiglia povera
ad un certo punto i genitori decidono di
abbandonare lui i fratellini nel bosco
pollicino frettolosamente uscendo di
casa con i genitori non riesce a
raccogliere i sassi e metterle in tasca
ma mette in tasca solo del pane di
semina il sentiero con le briciole
una volta che si perde nel bosco con i
fratellini cerca la strada del ritorno
ma non la trova perché il cellini hanno
mangiato le briciole però non si perde
d'animo va alla ricerca di una salvezza
vediamo a casa una casa bellissima dove
regna l'opulenza la ricchezza è un
miraggio
e lui quasi quasi si dimentica del suo
passato decide di andare verso questa
casa con la speranza di trovare il
benessere una vita più agiata
il secondo protagonista di questa storia
siamo noi noi tutti con la nostra
evoluzione il nostro percorso
ad un certo punto anche noi siamo rapiti
da quello che sembra essere il benessere
ci lasciamo andare e vediamo questo
miraggio per entrambi purtroppo si
manifesterà la triste realtà
pollicino
si troverà di fronte loro con la paura
di morire di essere divorato vivo per
noi l'inettitudine lo smarrimento e
l'incapacità di reagire
il terzo protagonista di questa storia è
un personaggio extra ordinario
faccio fatica a descriverlo io
personalmente samantha cristoforetti la
prima donna astronauta italiana che vola
sopra le nostre teste per sei mesi in
microgravità sulla stazione spaziale
internazionale e samantha cristoforetti
mi coinvolge direttamente in un progetto
fantastico decide di rivolgermi appunto
nella produzione di quello che viene
definito bonis food ossia del cibo che
servirà a lei durante la permanenza
nella stazione spaziale orbitante
ecco che sono preso dallo sgomento
infatti vedete che facce e la paura
arriva anche per me come arrivata per
pollicino mi trovo abbastanza smarrito
ma a samantha mi coinvolge in questa
avventura fantastica e da subito capisco
l'importanza di questa avventura
osservare l'astronauta significa avere
una lente d'ingrandimento puntata su ciò
che l'alimentazione può fare
sull'organismo umano non solo signori la
lente d'ingrandimento è utilissima
perché un astronauta un accelerati simo
invecchiamento cellulare
questo significa che più o meno sei mesi
di permanenza sullo spazio equivalgono a
10 anni per noi sulla terra
quindi abbiamo un panorama ristretto sei
mesi dove in realtà studiamo una persona
che invecchia 10 anni e questo è
fantascientifico se vogliamo lei decide
di formare una squadra forma una squadra
e attraverso il sito avamposto 42 dove
c'è un osteria ai confini dell'universo
compone un equipaggio formato da
tecnologi alimentari i medici
nutrizionisti uno chef un astronauta
iniziamo le ricerche ricerche
approfondite per dare una soluzione a
samantha che sia una soluzione
funzionale ossia dei prodotti che la
aiutino a preservare questo accelerato
invecchiamento cellulare accelerato
invecchiamento cellulare che significa
anche indebolimento del tessuto
muscolare indebolimento dell'apparato
scheletrico ritenzione idrica e
tantissime altre patologie
e già qui potremmo fare un primo
pensiero non sono le stesse patologie
che ogni giorno noi cerchiamo di evitare
e di curare sulla terra ed è stato
proprio durante queste ricerche io
personalmente mi sono dedicato
all'ingrediente istica ossia selezionare
gli ingredienti più adatti che fossero
gustosi ma che fossero anche funzionali
e ho scoperto una cosa fantastica
l'avessimo in due parole tradizione e
necessità facciamo qualche esempio
tradizione e necessità spesso
equivalgono
qui abbiamo qualche qualche esempio che
può essere rappresentativo anche per il
nostro territorio il baccalà e la sarde
in saor per necessità qualcuno si è
inventato di mettere al sole al vento un
pesce è diventato il baccalà un piatto
tradizionale italiano la stessa cosa
vale per le sarde in saor e sardista or
sono delle scorte sicure
per i marinai veneziani una carica
proteica assicurata dei grassi buoni ma
scoprirono anche la funzionalità
dell'alimentazione perché la vitamina c
contenuta nella cipolla abbondantemente
evitava che il marinaio si ammalasse di
scorbuto la malattia più comune fra chi
trascorreva lunghi periodi in mare
ecco che quindi per trovare il
versificata di tradizione dobbiamo fare
dei passi indietro
durante questa ricerca sono emersi anche
dei punti di domanda quale tradizione i
salumi la carne rossa i formaggi erano
costantemente presente nelle tavole dei
nostri antenati come lo sono oggi come
erano interpretati come veniva allevato
il bestiame come veniva coltivato come
veniva interpretato quella alimento
all'interno della dieta quotidiana
questa selezione degli ingredienti molto
accurata voleva dare un senso a quello
che noi abbiamo definito un metodo
alimentare il più aggiornato possibile
il più in linea possibile con le ultime
tecnologie e le ultime ricerche in campo
alimentare
quindi in definitiva signori miei per
cercare di creare il cibo del futuro
dobbiamo a girarci bisogna tornare
indietro e recuperare le consuetudini
gli usi i costumi i modelli e le norme
che hanno dato vita al prodotto quando è
nato a quel piatto che noi oggi
chiamiamo tradizionale solo recuperando
queste informazioni potremo recuperare
la strada queste parole rappresentano le
briciole di pollicino che noi abbiamo
perso per strada durante la nostra
storia quello che è nato
da questa ricerca e questo lo space sud
ingredienti semplici funzionali ripeto
che avessero la capacità di aiutare ad
proprio samantha a supportare al meglio
e sopportare al meglio la sua avventura
microgravità prodotti estremamente in
linea con la natura
qui abbiamo solo pochi ingredienti mela
per afragola cannella e del succo di
limone
altre caratteristiche dello space food e
il fatto di essere pratico di lunga
conservazione a temperatura ambiente 18
24 mesi addirittura in qualche caso il
36 gustose ovviamente sano ma anche qui
se ci fermiamo non è non sono le stesse
caratteristiche che dovrebbe avere il
cibo che che utilizziamo oggi dove non
abbiamo capacità è tempo di mettere in
discussione ciò che mettiamo dentro il
carrello o peggio ancora dentro il
nostro organismo dove spesso ci troviamo
a mangiare in macchina e dove in ufficio
spesso trascuriamo tutta la nostra
giornate ma oggi signori non per la
storia era per la favola che vi ha
raccontato purtroppo non ho un finale
finale dobbiamo scriverla noi abbiamo un
modello da seguire samantha
cristoforetti ci ha dato la possibilità
di capire meglio la strada la nebbia si
sta un po diradando e il futuro è quello
di trovare soluzioni che preservino al
massimo i valori nutrizionali degli
alimenti soluzioni che non sfruttino
necessariamente il calore
per portare a cottura un prodotto sembra
un'assurdità in realtà si può fare
soluzioni che possano essere sicure per
chi consuma il prodotto questo potremo
farlo solo se torniamo indietro
samantha cristoforetti ripeto ci ha
supportato in questo ci ha dato la
possibilità di studiare l'alimentazione
sull'astro nauta in questo laboratorio
di microgravità e concludo dicendo che
tradizione e innovazione è un concetto
che deve essere cambiato ritornare
all'ordine significa anche mettere i
puntini sulle i
e io aggiungo mettere gli accenti al
punto giusto quindi da oggi si parlerà
di tradizione che è innovazione grazie a
tutti i signori
ivo il bonus food che oggi ho portato
dall'italia mi sta salvando soprattutto
nei nei pranzi devo dire perché sono dei
sono delle buste concepito con il
concetto del piatto unico dove si mette
una combinazione quindi un quarto un
quarto diciamo di volume di carboidrati
un quarto di proteine quindi nel mio
caso ceo del pollo o dello sgombro e
quindi mangiando un pranzo al ghul ai
cobas a scaldare una busta e ci sono
queste questi ottimi piatti unici molto
gustosi e che mi danno la parola la
sicurezza che senza doverci pensare ho
già un piatto completo ho messo insieme
in maniera in maniera oculata dal dal
nostro chef stefano polato qui c'è uno
dei miei piatti spaziali preferiti
l'insalata di chi no con lo sgombro e lo
sgombero è un'ottima fonte di proteine
sane ma anche di grassi sani quelli di
cui abbiamo assolutamente bisogno per
mantenerci in buona forma in buona
salute e ottime fonti di grassi sale
sono naturalmente molti altri pesci ha
per esempio qui grazie ai colleghi russi
abbiamo anche dello storione nel mio
bonus food quindi dal mio bob personale
o anche delle
delle occasioni di assumere i grassi
sani nei momenti di degli snack per
esempio a me piace molto l'avocado e
quindi o del waka mole che mi piace
spalmare sul pane rigorosamente
integrale oppure per uno snack veloce
della frutta secca mandorle e noci e
naturalmente non ho dimenticato di
portare con me nello spazio l'olio
d'oliva che ravviva e da gusto anche
alle insalate reidratate che abbiamo qui
a bordo ha messo qualche esempio degli
snack sani che abbiamo qui a bordo della
stazione spaziale per esempio abbiamo
molta frutta purtroppo non fresca se non
in occasioni eccezionali abbiamo frutta
in buste termostabile dato come questa
questa per esempio è una macedonia di
agrumi oppure in buste disidratate come
questa che stessimo delle fragole
oppure abbiamo della frutta della frutta
essiccata che è molto simile a come
sarebbe sulla terra queste per esempio
sono delle delle mele essiccate che
fanno parte del mio bonus food italiano
un altro tipo di snack sano che abbiamo
qui a bordo sono i semi e la frutta
secca per esempio questa è una barra di
vari tipi di semi e in particolare i
semi di zucca e queste sono noci di
macadamia siamo molto
entrambe sono ottime fonti di proteine
sane e di grassi sani
e poi uno snack davvero particolare
questa barretta è stata fatta per me
dallo chef stefano polato in italia e
che contiene tanti degli ingredienti i
panni di cui abbiamo parlato proprio ora
quindi oltre cereali integrali tanta
frutta frutta secca semi è un
ingrediente particolare che si chiama
spirulina ho sentito che lo chef stefano
polato ci insegnerà anche come fare
questa barretta a casa il momento dello
snack dello spuntino è una ottima
opportunità di fare il pieno di se e
come sempre
niente panico nutrirsi in maniera sana è
roba da ragazzi